whenever Bruce Lee stepped onto the
screen he moved at ridiculous speeds
took out legions of bad guys with his
devastating punching power and inspired
audience members to sign up for martial
arts classes in droves let's take a look
at his most epic fight scenes in the big
boss Bruce Lee in his first leading role
plays a young man who's trying to avoid
fist fights after promising his mom he
wouldn't get into any more trouble
unfortunately things are kind of rough
at work
our hero spends his days sweating at an
ice factory and he soon discovers his
boss is secretly a drug dealer with a
bad habit of killing people including
members of Lee's family after his
cousin's go mysteriously missing Lee
explores the ice factory and finds his
relatives all chopped up and frozen but
before he can call the cops an army of
henchmen shows up armed with everything
from chains and knives to tongs and ice
choppers
fortunately for viewers Lee isn't afraid
to get inventive he blinds his enemies
with sawdust cracks a dude's head with a
flashlight and slashes at his foes with
a handsaw sure Lee is majorly
outnumbered but it doesn't seem to
matter he dodges knives and jumps over
thugs like he's Superman leaping tall
buildings when Lee gets his own blade
were treated to geysers of blood
spurting across the screen but the best
moment comes with Lee punches a dude
through a wooden shed leaving a Looney
Tunes style hole in the wall complete
with outstretched arms when Lee shows up
at the bad guys compound at the end of
the Big Boss he's so confident in his
abilities that he's snacking on chips
while fighting the drug dealers goons
and when he reaches the titular Big Boss
Lee picks him up over the head and
Chuck's him across the yard when the bad
guy pulls out some blades Lee uses his
own shirt to keep the drug dealer at bay
both dudes are jumping around crouching
tiger style and at one point in the
fight Lee takes the big boss to the
ground wraps his legs around the bad
guys legs and starts rolling across the
grass like a crocodile
finally the fight ends in the most
insane way possible the boss hurls a
knife at Lee
our man kicks it back into the dudes
stomach if that wasn't wild enough
that's when Lee sticks his hands into
the drug dealers guts it's a brutal
ending and thanks to Lee's high-flying
kicks and powerful punches the big boss
became the highest-grossing film in Hong
Kong history there's a lot of political
drama happening in Fist of Fury
including the students at a Japanese
dojo who have declared war on Bruce
Lee's Chinese martial arts school
wanting to show these guys some manners
Lee pays the bullies a visit and teaches
them a thing or two about Chinese
etiquette Lee just casually struts into
enemy territory like he's taking an
afternoon stroll and soon he's
surrounded by a circle of karate masters
it's a shot that obviously inspired the
crazy 88 battle and Kill Bill Vol - and
Bruce is just as devastating as the
bride when the bad guys rush in Lee
opens up the fight with eight massive
kicks in just six seconds sending guys
flying better still this is the first
time in cinematic history when Lee gets
to show off his nunchakus skills and he
whacks a whole lot of skulls before
dropping to the ground and slapping some
shins as the fight goes on the circle of
Fighters gets smaller and smaller until
Lee goes one-on-one with their teacher
screeching like a tiger he makes the
master look like an amateur and when he
finally leaves the dojo all the students
are on the floor Bruce Lee is like the
Chinese Terminator you can't stop him
all you can do is run
but while Lee usually walks through his
opponent's he finds a worthy adversary
in Fist of Fury when he goes toe-to-toe
with a Russian monster played by Robert
Baker Petrov is a Russian karate expert
and strongman who can bend metal bars
and drive nails into wooden boards with
his bare hands he's also a skilled
martial artist and unfortunately best
buds with a dude who murdered Bruce
Lee's master so when our hero shows up
for revenge first he's got to get
through this curly-haired behemoth
sporting a bowtie and suspenders Petrov
sends Lee staggering with a right hook
from hell and when the fight goes to the
ground the Russian nearly breaks Lee's
arm with an armbar while Petrov might
have the strength advantage Lee is
too fast so fast in fact that when he
starts doing his kung-fu moves it looks
like he has dozens of arms waving
through the air
it's a classic Bruce Lee scene and he
finishes the fight with a fatal chop to
the throat it just goes to show that
size doesn't matter when you're up
against those furious fists here's a
little tip for all you would be bad guys
don't murder Bruce Lee's master
that's something hero Shi Suzuki learns
the hard way in fists of fury the master
of a Japanese dojo Suzuki Hadleys
teacher killed so when our hero shows up
at the bad guys house he isn't there to
play nice but Suzuki is waiting with
katana in hand Lee quickly grabs a
wooden post but Suzuki whittles that
thing down to a toothpick after the
katana gets too close for comfort that's
when the nunchucks come out eventually
Lee knocks the sword across the room
then tosses his own weapon aside and
starts intercepting Suzuki's face with
his fists finally the battle comes to an
end when the two enemies jump at each
other and Lee kicks Suzuki through the
air sending him flying through the
paper-thin walls evidently it's one
powerful kick as the bad guy immediately
starts throwing up blood before Keeling
over dead Bruce Lee made his directorial
debut with way of the Dragon a comedic
kung-fu flick that has leaf flying to
Italy to help out some Chinese immigrant
friends of his it seems that after they
opened up a restaurant in Rome they ran
into trouble with the mob needless to
say these schlubby gangsters are no
match for Bruce Lee hoping to scare him
back to Hong Kong the gangsters take Lee
out behind the restaurant where he grabs
a wooden pole and shows off some bo
staff skills when more punks show up to
the party armed with chains and
switchblades Lee pulls out two pairs of
nunchucks and we all know exactly how
that goes
[Music]
then and perhaps the funniest scene in
any Bruce Lee movie a gangster gets his
own pair of nunchucks and tries to beat
Bruce Lee at his own game but he only
succeeds in whacking himself in the head
then when Lee goes back to the
restaurant to rescue his friends he
takes out some thugs with homemade
wooden darts Lee might not understand
Italian customs but he certainly knows
how to mess up some mobsters what do you
do when all your henchmen can't beat
Bruce Lee well if you're the evil crime
boss from way of the Dragon
you hired Chuck Norris of course he will
be the one who will personally take care
of that time the two legends Throwdown
in the Coliseum and after some pre
fights stretching the Battle of the
Titans begins Norris is absolutely
ferocious and it's clear this guy has
the strength advantage he drops leave
with a spinning roundhouse kick lands a
solid combination of elbows and body
shots and then judo tosses Lee to the
floor but everything changes when Lee
starts dancing around the Coliseum like
he's Muhammad Ali the movement makes all
the difference and the flat-footed
Norris can't keep up in a beautiful
slow-motion sequence we watch Lee dodge
and parry blows before unleashing a
stunning four kick combo that turns the
fight in his favor
eventually Lee brings the greatest
martial arts showdown to a close by
killing Norris with a sick guillotine
choke the movie that turned Bruce Lee
into an international star Enter the
Dragon follows our high-kicking hero as
he's tasked with joining a mysterious
martial arts tournament and bringing
down the criminal kingpin running the
contest but the stakes are personal for
Lee one of the competitors is
responsible for the death of Lee's
sister so when the two are pitted
against each other
Lee isn't going to turn the other cheek
played by martial artist Bob wall O'Hara
is the psycho on Lee's hit list the dude
has an attitude as big as the scar
running down his face and when he
squares off against Lee he tries to make
a big impression by punching a wooden
board in half but Lee isn't fazed and
famously tells his opponent oh don't
back Bruce Lee on the other hand hits
back a whole lot every time they face
off Lee lands the first blow and then he
sends O'Hara soaring with a scary
slow-mo kick infuriated O'Hara grabs
some broken bottles and plans on carving
Lee up but after a well-placed kicked
the jaw Lee jumps on the dudes head and
breaks O'Hara's neck after a whole bunch
of kung-fu battles throughout Enter the
Dragon the villainous han and leif
finally square off in the film's big
showdown a scene filled with classic
Bruce Lee moments there's the kick from
hell that nearly decapitates Han there's
the scorpion kick that leaves the
villain hurting and humiliated and then
there's the insane scene in which a
freshly cut Lee licks his own bloody
fingers to prove he's a savage finally
the showdown moves into a Hall of
Mirrors where Han uses the reflections
to his advantage hiding in plain sight
but after remembering some words of
wisdom from his old teacher Lee smashes
all the glass so there's nowhere left
for Honda hide the crazy scene comes to
an end when Lee side kicks Han so hard
that he flies straight into a spear Game
of Death is one of the biggest what-ifs
in movie history Lee only shot 40
minutes of the film before his untimely
death but his vision sounds epic the
plot was going to follow Lee as he
fought his way up a pagoda in search of
a valuable treasure each time he reached
a new floor who would face a new boss
who specialized in a specific martial
art Lee would have to overcome each
master with jeet kune do-- a philosophy
based on adaptability and using whatever
works in a fight regardless of style
however after Lee's death the plot was
completely changed a Bruce Lee
look-alike filled in for most of the
movie in only 11 minutes of the original
game of death footage showed up in the
final cut regardless of that the battle
with Dan Inosanto in the film is a
testament to Lee swagger and speed an
Escrima expert Inosanto relies on rattan
sticks to batter his opponents but Lee
fights back with a simple bamboo read
Lee is incredibly cocky here and it's so
fun to watch him dance strut and scream
his way through the fight eventually the
bad guy trades his sticks for
nunchuks and naturally he pulls out his
own pair that's when both guys start
twirling their weapons like their Wild
West gun fighters showing off their
tricks and the battle ends when leap
chokes out Inosanto with the nunchucks
Game of Death gave us two iconic images
Bruce Lee wearing the yellow and black
jumpsuit and the sight of Lee trading
blows with Kareem abdul-jabbar in the
theatrical release of the film
abdul-jabbar is a member of a syndicate
that blackmails movie stars and Lee's
longer original scene the NBA player was
the final boss at the top of the pagoda
guarding a treasure and accepting all
challengers in both versions it's David
and Goliath scenario as abdul-jabbar's
legs are almost longer than leaves
entire body sporting sunglasses and
short shorts the basketball player
batters Lee with looping punches and
long kicks leaving a massive footprint
on the front of Lee's cool yellow suit
for a good chunk of the fight Lee has
trouble closing the distance and while
he manages to get in some good shots
abdul-jabbar is so big that Lee gets
clobbered anytime he gets close however
in the original footage Lee discovers
the Giant has a weakness sunlight
he begins smashing out windows causing
abdul-jabbar to cringe and pain as light
floods the room eventually Lee knocks
the sunglasses off abdul-jabbar's face
leaving him defenseless as Lee locks in
a chokehold check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the belt so you don't
miss a single one
you